this certainly is an ideal but I have
contingencies you can't treat me any
more biometric scan complete
welcome back Peter shall I execute all
cancellation protocols no we execute
them all confirmed
thank you
how could you do all this you'll see
here people believe and nowadays
anything
busy
is this real all illusions are down
Peter
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my spider-man far from home
sinister six setup video so clearly Sony
wants to do a sinister six movie they've
been teasing it in spider-man homecoming
now again during spider-man far from
home so we'll break it down how Mysterio
survived and what that sinister six
movie is going to look like currently
and their original plans for their
sinister six spin-off franchise there's
a giveaway for the spider-man far from
home blu-ray all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
sinister six theory on the video so
obviously careful for spoilers for
spider-man far from home if you haven't
seen it yet we'll be talking about
everything that happens during the movie
all the Easter eggs that point to
sinister six starting with number ten so
you see it seems like Mysterio orders
the drones to turn off their proximity
safety feature to fire on spider-man
while he's at close range inadvertently
causing his own death via friendly fire
but the really important lines of
dialogue that they both have are they'll
see what I want them to see I have a
contingency plan people need to believe
in nowadays they'll believe anything
that phrasing will come back around in a
second because number nine Peter then
asks Edith if he's really dead but stop
short of it and instead uses the careful
phrasing is this real he doesn't
actually ask is Mysterio dead
Edith answers with the very carefully
worded all illusions are down she does
not say yes he's definitely dead that
leaves them a back door to bring him
back in a future sinister six team up
and say that they weren't lying like oh
we didn't say that he was dead we just
said that all illusions were down so
eight how was Mysterio actually able to
trick Peter if his spidey sense was
working in this moment and he could see
through the regular digital illusions
first you have to keep in mind that
Mysterio is a genius even though he had
all these funny lines of dialogue and
silly moments with Peter he was smart
enough to earn a job a high-level job at
Stark Industries next to Tony Stark
before he revealed how unstable he was
and got fired
he and his team of other super
intelligent former but unstable Stark
Industries employees had been working on
their contingencies for a long time when
this moment happened they weren't making
their plan up as they went along this
was carefully thought out and during the
movie
once they learned spider-man had
discovered what they were doing number
seven Mysterio started planning for this
moment during their final boss fight he
always knew that spider-man would
eventually come and try to stop him and
the only way to beat spider-man's spidey
sense when it was working at a hundred
percent because he says you can't trick
me anymore Peter finally using his
physical senses to see past the digital
illusions was for Mysterio to play to
his expectations and play on his
emotions his desire to believe in
something people need to believe these
days people will believe anything so
when it seems like he's dying is a bit
of a double meaning because he's playing
to Peter's expectations ago I finally
seen through his digital illusions so he
can't trick me anymore so Peters not
looking for any kind of practical
effects
that's why six Mysterio can use sleight
of hand in old-school trickery to fake
his death peter was only looking for the
illusions so once it seemed like
Mysterio actually got shot and he
pounded his way through those illusions
he thought that everything he was seeing
was real and because of the carefully
phrased dialogue from Edith she said all
illusions were down he thought that what
he was seeing was 100% real and Mysterio
was 100% dead but he wasn't thinking
about the idea Mysterio might have had
some other more practical way of faking
his death like using chemicals to slow
his heart rate down and make it seem
like he got shot with friendly fire and
died you never see what happens to his
body after Nick Fury comes to collect it
and you don't know that he comes to
collect it you just assumed that he does
because they jumped forward in time
Talos even says that the basic low-level
fakery that Mysterio was pulling during
the movie was enough to fool him
outright he was so ashamed of himself a
shapeshifter
he should be a master at spotting stuff
like that but turns out Talos sucks at
it and in real life it's actually
possible to fake your own death by
slowing your heart rate down so much so
that you appear to be dead for a period
of time you can make up all the
conspiracies you want about someone
swapping bodies after spider-man leaves
the scene of that crime you don't see
any kind of scene with him standing
there waiting for Nick Fury to come
collect the body before taking off you
just see him take off and go talk to MJ
right after that so there's a whole
period of unaccounted for time with
Mysterio's body lying there for them to
swap in a different one to make it seem
like he really did die five even if you
don't want to believe that Jake
Gyllenhaal might come back for sinister
six team-up there's William Ginter reeva
the understudy who now has a chance
to step into the limelight constantly
put upon even Mysterio didn't treat him
that well like he kept yelling at him
when they were making those illusions he
understands Mysterio's technology just
as much as Mysterio did and was there
for every minute of his plan he stole
all of Mysterio's gear in data when he
bolted right after that moment happened
the thumb drive itself just had the
video that Mysterio and he had edited
together a framing spider-man so Reba is
the one that sent that video to Jay
jonah Jameson in the Daily Bugle dotnet
but not only can he come back and make
himself look like Mysterio with the
illusion tech because all he needs is a
motion capture suit he can also use the
illusion technology to make people think
that he's the Quentin Beck version of
Mysterio he can make any kind of
illusions that he wants so either way
whether or not you think that he's dead
or he survived in this moment here they
can still bring back Jake Gyllenhaal for
sinister six the reason why they wrote
the ending to the movie this way though
is one to make it feel like a definitive
ending at least on the surface level
give spider-man his big victory you
can't trick me anymore big takedown of
the villain - because Jake Gyllenhaal
isn't known for doing a ton of sequels
and Sony could always decide that they
don't want to bring him back and just
build themselves a backdoor to say no he
was always supposed to die we never
planned on bringing him back even though
it was very ambiguous in three two leave
themselves the logical backdoor to say
that he faked it if they do want to
bring him back because of tricky
language that they used during these
scenes all illusions are down wait what
about him being dead though I know the
illusions are down but is he really dead
for talking about the other sinister six
Easter eggs during the spider-man
homecoming post-credits scene vulture
runs into the Scorpion who's got that
very mechanical looking scorpion like
bone brace while he heals from the fight
he says that he and a few friends are
looking to find out who's spider-man
really is so they can kill him
vulture did in the solid because
spider-man saved him earlier in the film
but thanks to Mysterio and Jay jonah
Jameson the whole world knows that Peter
Parker is spider-man now so enter
scorpion with the new version of the
Shocker Mysterio they have vulture to
bring back if they want to the Aaron
Davis Prowler in Donald Glover's
character that makes five characters
already in three right now it seems like
Kraven the hunter is gonna be the main
villain of spider-man 3 at least until
we hear something different it's just
that around the premiere of the movie
the director kept talking about how he
wanted to use Kraven in spider-man
three Sony teasing cravin during the
morbius movie you see this on the side
of the truck
so clearly Cravens first cinematic
appearance is imminent that makes six
characters that they can use in
spider-man 4 but what about a much more
powerful big bad to bring them together
a lot of you asking where is Norman
Osborn Green Goblin such a huge
character it feels weird for him not to
be anywhere or any kind of Oscorp in
spider-man movies so you can introduce
Norman Osborn in spider-man 4 as the
Green Goblin and you can still call it
sinister 6 even though technically that
would make seven characters there's
always a chance for Michael Keaton
vulture or someone else to not come back
so it works either way
but - yes venom could always be a
sinister six team member but here's the
thing that character is so big and
popular on his own I don't see why they
would need to do that when they can just
do sinister six in spider-man 4 and do a
spider-man venom team-up in a totally
different movie before venom 3 happens
or they could just save the first
spider-man and venom team up for venom 3
maximum carnage venom should be its own
thing
separate from sinister 6 and you've
probably seen all the rumors about them
doing even more Tom Holland films after
spider-man 4 there was a rumor a long
time ago about them doing 9 total Tom
Hollands spider-man films but it gives
you a better picture for how Sony
doesn't want to blow its wad in
spider-man 4 so that's why spider-man 3
isn't gonna be a full-blown sinister 6
movie just a single villain maybe with a
couple lesser ones leading up to a
sinister six movie and it's all because
number one Sony still wants to make
sinister 6 its own 3rd spider-man
spin-off franchise so consider venom a
spin-off franchise of spider-man
consider the Morbius movie and other
spin-off franchise what are the biggest
ideas characters and teams within the
spider-man rights that they could do
sinister 6 is just the easiest slam dunk
is all about trilogies or Cuadrilla G's
in the case of the Tom Hollands
spider-man films because we know they're
doing for spider-man films with him why
do sinister six one and done in a
spider-man movie when you can do three
sinister six movies with a rotating
roster of team members Thunderbolt style
this all goes back to Andrew Garfield
era when Drew Goddard was originally
going to start their sinister six
franchise he was going to do a sinister
six movie that was set up during
amazing spider-man twos post-credits
scene the sinister six movie was not
going to be amazing spider-man 3 amazing
spider-man 3 was going to be a totally
different plotline sinister 6 was going
to be a completely separate franchise so
everybody poster sinister 6 theories in
the comments below and obviously there's
all this venom crossover that we're
talking about that's completely separate
from the sinister six stuff I will do
more venom two videos in the next couple
of weeks I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post my next Marvel video
there'll be a whole bunch more stuff
coming up click here for my video about
Quicksilver coming back during Doctor
Strange 2 and click here for my
brand-new Rick and Morty season 4
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]